yeah it's funny because i've been
recommended like i would say not like a
similar
genre of youtube videos but just like in
the opposite sense which is
just youtubers who just climb really
high places
and like i kind of get that i don't know
why
i don't i i don't like similarly how
watching these cave divers you get like
uh claustrophobic
i get vertigo watching these people just
climb really high places i
i also have a fear of heights so just
watching i guess i can understand that
i'm like all right one you know normally
climbing is like
you know arguably climbing a tall
skyscraper is probably safer than going
down a cave
i mean probably i mean there's a
difference between the feeling of being
trapped and just you know
falling from a very high place i can i
can see why you get that
sense of freedom which is exactly the
opposite yeah that's what i think i can
understand that you know
you get the view and it's pretty cool i
kind of get it even though i know it's
interesting yeah yeah
i'm not gonna lie either way finn a pass
on yeah yeah because because like i got
recommended this video and the title of
this video was
reflecting on the day i almost died and
i'm just like oh man this is a it's
getting a bit too real here
and it's just this guy who is climbing
up this really tall building in hong
kong
right and it's it's just like this pov
shot and it's just him doing commentary
over it
right and so he climbs up this really
tall building in the middle of uh
like from kind of like dawn so before
the sun rises
and by the time he gets to the top the
sun starts rising
and so you have this really tall
skyscraper and on top of this skyscraper
there's just like this really
rickety scaffolding that goes that goes
like off like another mile or something
you know what i mean
right and so he he starts climbing up
this when it's when it's like dark and
by the time he gets to the top
the sun has risen and you can see the
view um and then it starts raining
oh no and he's up there by himself and
in the commentary
he he says he says that i had two
choices
either i could wait up there wait out
the rain and just kind of risk
someone would see me and getting a
rescue attempt and i'd probably get
arrested
or i could just attempt to climb down
even though that would be
i would be more likely to slip off and
die so of course
he decides
like like getting arrested and being
rescued this is literally the horror
movie split up or stating no that's
not that's what i'm saying right these
people make the decisions
to do what we see as like the dumber
decisions
i feel like if you're the type of person
who's gonna climb up a skyscraper you're
gonna be the type of guy who climbs down
a skyscraper i mean i guess in his head
he was like
either way i have to climb down so i
might as well just do it now i think
i think there also is a fair amount of
people who would rather die than be
arrested
maybe there is i no i genuinely believe
there's a section before
i don't want a criminal record so bad
i'd rather not exist i'm gonna die here
before i told
who would rather take that risk honestly
yeah probably
because in some countries especially
about you get that [ __ ] oh your life's
ruined it's a you know
true true america
most most developed countries yeah i
mean like it's
i mean i i find it interesting to watch
people would go through this stuff
but yeah i mean i could never do it
myself i i think the most i would want
to do is skydive and
maybe bungee jump but the more i hear
about bungee jumping the less
i want to go through it for me bungee
jumping is a hard part
because you see well i think it's bungee
jumping it very much depends on uh where
you're doing it and
what company you're doing it with is it
or is it some dude and his mate with a
truck and yeah
are you in a country with health and
safety regulations that's the biggest
thing i think about
i hear people like doing it in like
places where i'm like i don't think you
should be bungee jumping i've i've seen
and heard
more bungee jumping accidents happen
than skydiving accidents
so just like weighing out the ratio i
find that skydiving might
be slightly better also people bungee
jump over like uh
water more often than not and you don't
want to slap that water yeah yeah yeah
bye bye a lot of water [ __ ] hurts
when you slap it at that stage that's
for you sorry
i mean it hurts when you're like belly
flop from like two meters up
let alone alone like 30 meters